je m'appelle ce terme de la terrasse et
je suis responsable rh chez crédit
agricole cib en service il
[Applaudissements]
crédit agricole perd mains de services
it est une filiale du groupe crédit
agricole leader des solutions de
paiement en france avec près de 30% de
parts de marché credit agricole payment
service il conçoit et développe des
solutions de paiement innovantes dans un
marché dynamique et en perpétuelle
transformation ont recruté en recherche
régulièrement des profils d'ingénieurs
qui sont passionnés par l'innovation et
le monde des paiements nous recherchons
un poste à pourvoir sur le site de saint
quentin en yvelines celui de responsable
d'application monétiques à destination
des commerçants ce métier consiste à
mettre à disposition des solutions de
paiement pour les commerçants
concrètement en quoi ça consiste
eh bien le responsable d'application
doit délivrer des projets donc
comprendre le besoin du client lui
proposait d'une solution adaptée et puis
après réaliser un cahier des charges
ensuite il doit participer à la
construction de cette solution
informatique cette application est enfin
il doit assurer une veille technologique
pour justement concevoir des solutions
de paiement de demain nous recherchons
des profils d'ingénieurs passionné par
les nouvelles technologies des
compétences informatiques bien sûr ici
du monde de lahti spécifiquement une
maîtrise des tartines architecture & cie
et puis avec des personnes ayant un bon
sens relationnel une orientation client
voilà ça ce sont des atouts que nous
recherchons